Atresia of the duodenum
is a birth defect
in which the first part of
a baby's small intestine,
called the duodenum, is blocked.
Located between the stomach
and large intestine,
the small intestine absorbs
nutrients from food.
The small intestine has
three parts, the duodenum,
the jejunum, and the ileum.
The duodenum forms during
the sixth week of pregnancy.
Here you can see
the tube that will
become the digestive system.
The duodenum grows just
below the developing stomach.
The cells inside the
duodenum grow so fast
that the tube becomes
blocked for a while.
Later, as part of
normal development,
the cells blocking the
inside of the duodenum
die off until the developing
intestine is open again.
By about the 10th week of
pregnancy, for unknown reasons,
the outside wall of the duodenum
may not have grown properly.
In addition, the cells blocking
the inside of the duodenum
may not have died off.
As a result, a defect
called duodenal atresia
in which a part of the duodenum
is blocked in one or more ways.
It may be blocked by a web
of tissue lining the inside
or a section of the duodenum
may be completely missing.
Finally, the duodenum
may be narrowed.
Any of these types of
atresia prevent the baby
from absorbing
nutrients from milk
because the fluid can't
pass through the duodenum.
Duodenal atresia is not
immediately life-threatening.
But it will require in
operation within a few days
after birth to repair
the blocked duodenum.
Before the operation,
a suction tube,
or NG, inserted soon after
birth through the nose or mouth,
will remove excess fluid
and air from the stomach.
The baby will be given
general anesthesia
to put him or her to sleep
for the entire operation.
A breathing tube
will be inserted
through the nose or mouth
and into the windpipe
to help the baby breathe
during the operation.
Commonly, the surgeon
will make an incision
under the ribs on
the right side.
Next, the surgeon
will carefully find
the atresia, or narrow
and blocked part
of the baby's duodenum.
Two incisions will be
made in the duodenum
above and below the atresia.
The surgeon will use sutures to
connect the two openings, thus,
bypassing the atresia.
Finally, the surgeon will
close the skin incision
with dissolvable sutures
or skin closure strips.
After the operation,
the baby will
be taken to the Neonatal
Intensive Care Unit
for monitoring.
Pain medication will be given.
The baby may continue to receive
antibiotics through the IV.
The baby will be released from
the hospital within two to four
weeks when the digestive
system is working normally.